FRONT. GOOD STOP
IT'S A QUICK SHOT ON THE NET,
FLOOR CHECK.
HOLDING UP THE POINT, HE TAKES
TTLE HALF RIGHT PAST SAVE.
>> NASHVILLE WILL SEND THIS
INTO NEUTRAL.
HERE T T
THEY CAN AND WILL
CROSSL
HE LOOKS LIKE HE'S ALWAYS GOING
TO PASS, HERE IS ANOTHER
HERE THEY ARE.
WATCH HIS HEAD TURN INTO THE
GLOVE.
THAT ALLOWS THVE ON FIVE, ONCE
N JOSI ON THE STICK, HE
SENDS  IRES IT
. HANG ON, ITE IS A GOAL.THAT Q
ON A FAMILIAR STREAK, HE'S
TRYING TO GET
2-3 ON THE POWER PLAY, THERE'S
A QUICK SHOT BY THE DEVILS. WAT
GO FROM THE  N. . PREDATORS ARE
ARE A VERY BIG THIRD PERIOD
TEAM.
IT, BUT HE MISSES THIS ONE.
WAY DOWNWN THE
PREDATORS MAKE IT COUNT AS THEY
PUT
LOOK AT THEM, EVERY SINGLE
>> JUST LIKE THAT, THE DEVILS
EATING THREE OTHER PLAYERS TO
DOMINATE THE GOAL LINE AND
JONATHAN BERNIER HAS TO LOOK
AROUND TRAFFIC, PUSH OFF.